bonsoir bonsoir magnifique vous êtes
magnifique non merci je me sens
magnifique csu piste est assez jupiter
oui ouisme et son magnifique c'est sa
danse et jupiter uranus parce qu'il faut
dire les capricornes de la première
semaine de janvier dont vous êtes mon
certes je sais je suis du 6 janvier
voilà comme moi et comme jeanne d'arc eh
bien ils ont un très bonne uranus est un
très bon suffit terre et ça c'est le
renouveau voilà et je me sens en plein
renouveau dans ce cas vous avez l'air en
forme je suis très enfants alors vous
êtes ici ce soir cheikh elizabeth pour
remettre les pendules à l'heure car
cette fois on en a la preuve vos
prévisions étaient justes cette fois à
l'umd la maintenant là tu vas par
laurent ont commencé que l'épidémie de
grippe aviaire par exemple un alors dans
un livre qui s'appelle votre horoscope
2006 que vous avez écrit en juin 2005
oui vous dites page 29
menaceront épidémies et problèmes
d'environnement
spécialement de la fin janvier à la mi
mars laurent je suis scotché
page 31 vous dites 16 mars épidémie
intoxication problème de santé publique
ouais j'ai cogné à lahti cunha tout ça
c'était surtout concentrée au début de
ce2 cette année et il risque d'y avoir
une resucée en septembre aux usa et le
triomphe modeste là quand même non non
c'est parce qu'en fait pour moi vous
allez dire que ceux-ci modeste mais j'en
fais très souvent des des prévisions à
ce point là quand même mais attendez
thierry congé prévu deux fois de suite
l'élection de chirac alors que tout le
monde disait que c'était le cas le
premier maire
non mais la première c'est la dure les
chauffeurs de taxi dans paris se marrer
en me disant on attendait balladur va
passer au premier tour moi je dis non
non ça m'attire accentuera et la
deuxième fois on me disait saisissent
pas à tous les coups et bien non et en
même temps si vous voulez je n'ai pas la
science infuse ouenza parce que s'il
m'arrive aussi de me tromper parce qu
apparemment non non il m'arrive de me
tromper non mais vous savez quand je me
trompe c'est pas l'astrologie qui se
trompe c'est l'astrologue il faut être
il faut rester humble 1 mais bien sûr
mais là concrètement parce que je sais
qu'il ya d'autres choses où vous avez
bon je vais en faire l'inventaire là
c'est bon ça fait quinze ans que tu ne
reçois et zabeth sur 15 ans c'est la
première fois qu'elle a bon
mais il m'a déjà rendu justice plusieurs
c'est vrai non mais là c'est étonnant tu
vas voir je continue autre prévision qui
s'est avérée juste
l' affaire des caricatures de mahomet
oui dans votre horoscope 2006 donc je
répète qu'il était écrit en juin 2005
malheureusement il est plus grand que tu
profites en mais ça vous le saviez
28 et 29 un climat général de fanatisme
religieux un climat dangereux touchant
aux croyances et aux idées il ya
toujours des risques donne s'est passé
parce que je les situer début de la nuit
là j'entends bien non mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya des décors et le sens né sais
pas c'est pas le descriptif complet de
l'histoire des casques yatuu honorant un
climat général de fanatisme religieux
c'est pas de la voyance donc on peut
juste
ni chez moi je peux te près je veux pas
l'organiser je peux quand même de
prédire pour l'année prochaine oui des
tensions sociales oui mais quand laurent
camp mais les rôles est clair je veux tu
veux des dates en avril 2009 après
l'émission je vais faire la sélection ce
soit filmé et 20 pour le mois de mai de
l'année prochaine je sens détention
je sens une pandémie et des détentions
dans au moyen-orient beaucoup de
tensions au moyen-orient nouveau
président pour 2007 aller
je le sens comme ça
bien
c'est que ça arrive je veux qu'on me
rende hommage c'est bien sûr et tu
viendras avec une écharpe orange bien
c'est bon mais j'adore les champions
bon alors je continue en étudions dans
les affaires on est toujours dans la
sphère des caricatures de mahomet en
page 31 dérives sectaires et mystico
religieuse
il va dire que c'est pas si c'est
marrant quand même là là là vraiment je
comprends pas alors si elle avait écrit
il aura des caricatures de mahomet ça va
très mal se passer c'est la bête décrit
l'événement c'est pas vrai je
m'inclinerai ouais là je ne suis pas
encore bluffé orf ah bon je sais pas ce
qui s'y dit que c'est en janvier c'est
vrai oui c'est pas grave si ça c'est pas
mal mais c'est pas non mais c'est plutôt
bien par rapport à d'habitude on est
d'accord
c'est
continué m ok mais je continue ou non
mais alors le plus fort c'était pour moi
c'est toujours dans votre horoscope 2006
qui était écrit je leur ai pas attendu
sa page 35 une fois j'en viens pas les
noms mais parce que la chine lâche
obligés de reconnaître page 35 la france
en 2006 un climat de bruit de fureur
jeunesse enseignement et chômage à la
une opposition galvanisé laurent au
début de l'année bien sûr
que
c'est précisément par ac c'est récurrent
aussi les messieurs les usa avec
balladur en 95 bah oui justement oui
avec wii avec juppé en 84 jours c'est
très intéressant ce que dit laurent
l'instant c'est que parce qu'il ya un
cycle de onze ans et 95 et 2006 a fait
onze ans et le cycle de jupiter donc je
m'étonne pas on peut déjà dire
aujourd'hui qui aura la même chose en
2006 + 11 passé loin j'avais 17 ans
elle n'a pas écrit un bouquin sur les
matins
pourtant ils font savoir je continue
toujours sur le cpe alors prise de
conscience collective retour aux
problèmes endémiques celui de
l'enseignement risque d'être le casus
belli déclenchant
d'accord thierry sur le très bien qu'on
m'avait invité gentiment à la fin de
l'année dernière en octobre vous avez
même déjà relevé ça en me disant mais
alors en somme vous voyez un nouveau mai
68 ou m'avait dit et j'ai dit oui et
voilà et magnéto serge
ce qu'on prévoyait c'est un mai 2006 un
peu comparable à mai 68 à vous vous
dites mais on n'est pas loin d'une
situation insurrectionnelle elizabeth
white beaucoup chômage enseignements des
crises dans tous les sens
l'enfant n'a
non c'est pour barrer la
route à ces films et la série
salut les 2600 le mai 68 dans le g10 je
vais rigoler saint-thomas mais ça reste
des marronniers de l'actualité des
choses récurrents la la mémé 68 atteint
alors là je me rends pas compte tout ce
que je veux quand même dire un truc
c'est que j'ai fait le thème ce après
midi de leurs profits sur l'internet et
j'ai vu qu'il était ascendant scorpion
et j'ai vu un truc hallucinant c'est que
c'est un gars qui a vraiment bon coeur
qu'ils aillent venus en emploi sont
sûrement mars qui est le signe d'une
attraction sexuelle irrésistible
je vois qu'on attend ce soir
c'était un amour contrarié pas non mais
surtout c'est un type qui a bon coeur
mais alors pourquoi il choisit d'être
systématiquement de prendre des victimes
comme ça puis j'ai vu que vous aviez
donné une interview à gala où on m'avait
dit que vous m'aimiez pas et là ça m'a
vraiment fait mon n8 non dans quel
journal chez des gens qu'elle a oui bon
c'est pas du genre à compter des billets
que avec robin wood kouyias que qu'avec
robin williams et bien vous pouviez pas
m'encadrer s'est trouvé ça m'a fait là
bas mes mots ça j'ai dit que vous étiez
un indécrottable exact ça oui alors ça
veut dire que le portugal en a partout
non c'est une image comment vous
expliquer
bah oui je pense que nos rapports ne
peuvent que s'améliorer oui je pense que
c'est ce soir ou jamais sur l'histoire
de mai 68 en 2006 et est d'accord là
d'accord je suis d'accord puisse pas
épaté mais je suis d'accord continue
mais lorsque sûrement pas justement
c'est pourquoi vous êtes si souvent
brocardé mois primo je suis emblématique
de l'astro à tort ou à raison c'est
comme ça donc quand on tire sur
l'astrologie c'est sur moi continue et
pour moi c'est très dur parce que ça
fait quand même trente ans et là je suis
dans une dans une période saturnienne de
bilan et je réfléchis à ses 30 ans où je
dois dire querido sûr que ça regarde
personne et finalement tout le monde
s'en fout que c'est juste mon destin à
moi je dois dire que j'en ai vraiment
ras le bol pas demain que non non pas du
tout non non pas du tout non mais de 7
mois donc non
non non c'est non est-ce que d'abord là
j'en ai marre maintenant je dis stop
ouais j'en ai marre d'être le punching
ball stop d'accord jaloux parce qu'on me
traite d'une façon irrespectueuse depuis
30 ans et journée là on pourra plus
faire ce soir non non non non non non
non non une dernière fois non
je demande ça va là tout va très bien
est ce que c'est un bon jour pour faire
cette émission oui c'est très bien bien
une pleine lune est un peu excité c'est
quand même pénible c'est bon on arrive
sur ta lune c'est bon appel le nom ouais
ben ça dépend ça m'énerve mois à bombay
lui c'est l'énervent parce qu'elle est
justement en déliés son séjour de le
jour qui précède la près de l'une la
plaine mais surtout là oui je suis
énervé là c'est vraiment non mais ne me
prenez pas comme alors que disait mon
père alors c'est plutôt bien on et ça ça
sera entre cadila mon cher adacore 80
euros d'accord
pour que j'ai bien compris le côté
quat'zyeux à oui non vous êtes toujours
brocardé pourtant l'astrologie c'est une
science inquiéter enseigner autrefois et
c'est pas un don passif comme la voyance
là où l'aca
[Rires]
dominique lery c'est moi qui te fait
rien c'est
non mais bon sérieusement c'est pas
demain signifie bien je ne sais pas
c'est pas un don passive c'est une c'est
une science c'est quelque chose qu'on
doit qu'on doit apprendre donc vous dire
c'est pas n'importe non mais ces
missions c'est ce que je vous dise prête
alors ce qui est égyptien non mais vous
même quand vous faites une thèse à la
sorbonne avec un jury prestigieux doit
vous êtes attaqués
mais c'est vrai sans
959 sens large vous êtes attaqués par le
monde un journal le monde et par par guy
carlier non le monde je n'ai pas été
attaquée ils ont raison fait c'était
sympathique elle a une là dessus il
avait été scié docteur en sociologie
ascendance ascendant capricorne non mais
c'est après figurez-vous thierry que
maintenant nous sommes en 2006 a fait 50
j'ai fait cette mal je sais bien sûr
l'avion je continue ce pas si vous voyez
dans dans les dents dans les médias
quand on veut dire que le truc est
merdique c'est comme la thèse de tessier
j'ai choisi car les c'est ça qui va di
caro non au cari a dit ce qu'il a dit
mais moi je regardais pas sur ça je fais
un procès à ces espèces d'immondes type
un bon copain je devais écouter il m'a
comparé à débat au bar buffet c'est
comique c'est comme il est mais j'ai pas
rigoler il m'a comparé aux barbus qui
jette des boeing contre les tours et il
m'a comparé aux 6 à une adepte de la
secte raël alors comme moi je ne suis je
suis anti sceptre maximum à l'astrologie
n'a rien à voir avec une secte c'est
quelque chose qui se vérifie d'après les
cycles la mémoire moi ça me tue moi
alors là j'ai dit non c'est ce que j'ai
voulu lui en coller une j'ai dit à l'ats
alain delon qui était à côté de moi je
lui dis je me lève je suis encore l'une
me dit fais pas ça et je tends que
celui-là tu ne crains rien mais qui n'a
pas ouvertes non plus il n'a pas défendu
parce que ce n'est pas maintenant parce
qu'ils sont comment mais il ya des
passages obligés compagnie
du si que les bacs + 16 points quand
même non mais ça personne n'en parle
jamais oui j'étais une idiosyncrasique
monsieur hasselhoff donc si madame irma
voilà et d'ailleurs on continue de dire
que citoyen je pense que la presse aime
bien dire que le voyant parce qu'ils
savent que ce dès
lors malgré tout vous continuez vous
accomplissez votre destin de figures
emblématiques de l'astrologie c'est pas
facile hein vous en bavez non maison des
marins way out est à ce point là oui
j'en ai marre je suis prête à vous
arrêter on pourra faire une grande fête
géniale faisant grande fête c'était
maison il est il est voyant parce que je
les décidé aujourd'hui avec mon éditeur
qu'on allait faire une grande volonté
oui j'ai des dons en fait est ce que est
ce que finalement vous êtes pas soumis à
tout ça parce que vous êtes né le 6
janvier comme jeanne d'arc quick on a
brûlé exactement et en plus j'ai eu un
accident quasi mortel presque mortel à
19 ans et j'ai rencontré une voyante non
mais je vais pas dire ça ici parce qu'on
va me prendre pour une dingue non non on
doit réfléchir
mais dites moi maintenant y en avait
trop dit non non mais c'est à qui vous a
dit que
non mais vous avez un accident non j'ai
eu un accident et 19 ans et elle et elle
a été brûlée à 19 ans elle est non mais
ce qui est absolument hallucinant c'est
que non seulement c'est dingue mon vieux
maître avant de mourir m'avait dit c'est
lui qui m'avait révélé que le thème de
naissance de de jeanne d'arc que j'avais
monté sur l'ordinateur et non seulement
elle avait son ascendant au même endroit
deux mois pile une chance sur 360 sans
mercure au même endroit une chance sur
vous savez pourquoi et quand louis
pauwels m'a soufflé le titre de mon
livre ne brillait pas la sorcière c'est
là que j'ai dit à mon vieux maître il
m'a dit mais vous savez que vous êtes
née le même jour que jeanne d'arc et on
me brûle depuis trente ans et c'est ça
j'aurais pu faire autre chose vous étiez
manne cachée chez coco chanel mannequin
vedette un oui star de cinéma faisait
tourner avec carnet broeck à beerse
lancaster vous connaissiez fellini et
c'est lui c'est fellini qui vous en
croisez dans l'astrologie c'est quand un
capricorne et c'est dommage pourquoi
c'est dommage parce que vous êtes
malheureuse depuis tout à l'heure vous
nous dites que vous souffrez le marché
non mais il ya des moments où vous savez
c'est un tirage quinte elle régale
intellectuelle l'astrologie c'est un
régal ouais parce que c'est d'abord
c'est un défi de l'intelligence parce
que c'est un défi c'est un défi
permanent pourquoi parce que la soul osi
est une création pourquoi parce que il
ya aucun instant où la configuration
globale est similaire à un autre moment
du passé
jamais jamais deux situations qui se
reconnaît jamais pas pourtant à dire ça
se reproduit en 6 en spirale mais si
vous voulez la confiture il ya des
soucis khl qui se retrouvent toujours
nouveau alors c'est toujours nouveau et
c'est pour ça que ça défi parce que
c'est une création parce que il faut
sortir de soi-même il faudrait en
quelque sorte que l'astrologue possède
déjà en soit la totalité de l'univers et
de ce qui est possible pour être
toujours dans le vrai et ça c'est
impossible c'est que je me suis mis moi
l'astrologie c'est vrai bah je vais vous
dire j'ai des courses j'ai fait quelques
prévisions vous allez me dire si à
longvic interview ouardi logis
alors moi je vois que la france sera pas
championne du monde
se connaît pas la date il faut décider
de lazzarotto sur des dates ça se mange
pas de date manche où il faut une date
précise mais je ne vais pas
malheureusement c'est ça le problème ah
oui c'est qu'on n'a pas la date non vous
n'allez pas pouvoir nous dire là bas non
parce que si vous me donniez une date
voilà le thème de la france le 20 juin
20 juin ça c'est les horaires des trains
non ce sont les positions des places des
plats nef le 20 juin
c'est pas mauvais à l'esade le 21 mars
et
ça serait mieux si ça serait mieux si ça
se passait autour du 24 là je dirai où
l'on va appeler
le responsable
en juillet vous juillet vous voyez
juillet feu d'artifice pour le 14 ou par
un appel razafy incendies en corse moi
j'ai giboulet pour mars et beaucoup de
cadeaux à noël l'histoire du cpe là il
va y avoir des retombées tous à début
mai fin avril la laissez pas fini je
pense on se penche chirac se
représentera ou pas moi je crois pas je
pense pas non plus mon nom sans qu'on
est d'accord oui bien madame tout le
monde est d'accord
la clairvoyance et pas la voyance
j'essaye tu vois
elle aussi va dire chaîne
les socialistes vont se tirer dans les
pattes à l'automne
enfin ça c'est certain de toute façon là
ils reprennent du poil de la bête extra
mais je sens même des feuilles mortes au
début email
en complément des piges au sérieux oui
oui d'accord avec ça oui tout à fait
bien s'enregistrer c'est à dire que
après on diffusait envers moi je fais
moi qui aura du monde sur le périph
demain à 19 heures des trucs en or mais
moi j'ai tout noté et on fera comme avec
vous ouais c'est bien la prochaine fois
vous venez on regarde
witsel a bon pour une fois devrait pas
trop emmerder on n'ira que ça va pas
s'arranger moi ce que je vois c'est pas
un non moins dans les bijoux pour ceux
en revanche c'est que j'avais donné une
interview à métro où j'ai pris j'avais
fait le thème de ma roue mais jean lyall
iranien oh la la ah ouais alors lui je
vais vous dire j'ai une trouille bleue
de ce type
il a un thème diabolique diabolique il
est scorpion aux lions bon il est la
nuit noire et or à nu sur son soleil si
je me sens bien il a des trucs très très
dur et je pense qu'il est dit pour
détruire et c'est ça qui fait peur et
j'avais écrit qu entre le 25 février et
le 25 avril il allait se passer quelque
chose en rapport à l'iran et regardez la
maison annoncé que j'allais faire une
fois de plus j'ai très très peur je vois
tu vois la moelle est parti j'ai un
voyant qu'ils déconnent dans ma bagnole
tu fais pas ta vie tu sais que tu me
dises iliad huile ou pas assez tôt
tiens est ce qu'il ya des manifs en
france depuis dix ans nous tenons
si si il y aura des manifs en juillet en
août bah écoutez c'est incroyable non
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai marqué gens
sont en vacances j'ai marqué non ça
c'est alizé cornet
des poireaux fin juin début juillet
c'est possible ça qu'ils
le trouvaient des bg arrive à pas la fin
je vois déjà certains messages
moi je l'avais trouvé avec emphase on
est en fait c'est ici que je me casse la
saison les
bulls
actuellement les mêmes les mêmes
prévisions il avait déjà loupé la marche
bien c'est là je suis très embêté parce
que j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle quelle
nouvelle je prévois qu'un acteur célèbre
très aimé du public nour avant le mois
de septembre
mais français français battait tout
20-13 et mais très ému les aimait pas
qu'on a croisés c'est trop long et trop
vague il faut dire quel jour
des trucs comme ça d'entrée mag jeudi
quand les est mort d'artistes peu savent
et c'est moi je crois que nicolas
sarkozy prendra ses distances avec le
gouvernement prendra ses distances à la
rentrée
bombe à bord non non j'ai pas non non
moi je crois pas non mais non au
contraire il est il est dans une passe
difficile là
il va avoir un moment encore difficile
jusque le mois de juin pour lui ça va
pas être facile voilà voilà une
prévision voilà on lui soutient moi
j'avais dit qu'ils professionnel j'ai
enchaîné octobre je vais début juillet
pas bon oui mais après quand jupiter
justement va être en sagittaire pour lui
et pour tout les verso de la fin janvier
ce sera excellent c'est à dire à la fin
de l'année 2006 là et vous pensez que
ségolène va le battre en 2007 elle a des
étoiles fantastique l'année prochaine
voyez c'est marrant bruit ça on est
d'accord encore une fois là dessus non
mais attends meilleur que maintenant
encore meilleur maintenant au lot toledo
a essayé dans la région parisienne pour
voir sa
meilleure main tant que non mais attends
est ce que ça cache main ou l'allemand
est ce que ça sera suffisamment
important pour subjuguer la france
complètement et voilà de tension des
élections bon ciel en face d'elle
sarkozy qui a également des étoiles
assez intéressante
avait donc bien de quel projet toile
il faut que j'ai pas été analysé en
détail en quoi
notre site à cette souche a convaincu la
non mais là tu tu reconnais que mais
bien sûr ce sans reconnaître non mais
moi je les avais
un deux trois quarts
on reste dans le gard est
tellement mignonne et en vrai alors
aussi je viens de lui dit ah oui c'est
la soeur de guy carlier
non il n'aurait pas s'être fait cela
pour quoi car toros coop vous devez nous
donner l'audience de l'émission de ce
soir
alors je dirais attention avant pâques
pau
28 et demie 28,2 note karine note
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu